ein quadratischer betonklotz mitten in
berlin dort wo die spree einen bogen
macht ist für drei unerschrockene das
ziel aller träume
das kanzleramt der beiden hatte kampf um
den mühseligen und beladenen shop wird
in den nächsten monaten alles andere in
den schatten stellen
schwierig wird auch eine andere berufung
die des propheten baerbock laschet
scholz wer die besten chancen jetzt in
der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst die zugeschalteten aus leipzig
ist zugeschaltet halten aus leipzig ist
zugeschaltet anhängig see ist
redakteurin im dortigen büro der zeitung
dortigen büro der zeitung die zeit und
martin florack ist von außen
zugeschaltet politikwissenschaftler
willkommen bei uns und im studio helene
bukowski parlamentskorrespondent in der
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung in
berlin und albrecht von lucke berlin und
albrecht von lucke redakteur der
politischen monatszeitschrift blätter
für deutsche und internationale politik
toporowski noch viereinhalb monate bis
zur bundestagswahl wie sich die augen
des tages war wie soll ich die
ausgangslage der drei aspiranten
na ja wir haben es mit einer in mehrerer
hinsicht einmaligen situation zu tun zum
ersten mal seit der gründung der
bundesrepublik deutschland tritt ist ist
sie wird der wahlkampf nicht aus dem
kanzleramt geführt die bundeskanzlerin
die 16 jahre regiert hat tritt nicht
mehr an hinterlässt damit eine
lehrstelle in der cdu die immer noch
dabei ist sich zu finden die grünen sind
auch in einer einmaligen situation zum
ersten mal stellen sie eine
kanzlerkandidatin auf die sich auch
mittlerweile kann man das so sagen
wirklich echte chancen ausrechnen kann
auf das kanzleramt und die spd stand in
ihrer geschichte noch nie so schlecht da
wie jetzt und in den umfragen liegt sie
zwischen 14 und 15 prozent also in jeder
hinsicht einmalig und natürlich deswegen
auch extrem spannend die frage wer die
besten chancen hat aber leicht zu
beantworten eigentlich leichter bei
anderen ist es aber eigentlich gar nicht
er von lucke aus dem zweier duell das
sonst üblich war ist jetzt ein dreier
duell geworden hat das einfluss auf den
wahlkampf diese dreier konstellation
statt der zweier konstellation wenn es
denn eine richtige dreier konstellation
noch wird man muss ja fast sagen dass
wir gegenwärtig eine neue bipolarität
haben man könnte davon sprechen dass die
grünen jedenfalls in umfragen zufolge
die spd regelrecht ersetzt haben und das
ist natürlich ein echter einschnitt
allerdings würde ich nicht völlig
ausschließen dass dieser hype ist der
falsche begriff aber diese ungemeine
konjunktur der grünen die ja fast
maximale geschlossenheit demonstriert
haben im gegensatz zur chaostruppe cdu
csu
so eine völlige verkehrung der
bisherigen situation die grünen
geschlossen zum kanzlerkandidaten zur
kanzlerkandidatin bekommen die cdu/csu
sich regelrecht selbst zerstören das ist
eine lage bei der man fast vorerst nicht
vorstellen kann dass die grünen einen
pick fast erreicht haben und ich halte
es noch für nicht ausgemacht dass diese
bipolarität gesetzt ist das nicht doch
vielleicht wenn es richtig hart wird und
wie joschka fischer hat mal das
kanzleramt reist die todeszone der
politik beschrieben das wird jetzt für
annalena baerbock auch eine todeszone
des wahlkampfes denn da bricht jetzt
glaube ich noch vieles auf und dann
könnte in der tat olaf scholz der ja der
einzige das muss man sich schon bewusst
machen das ist die eigentlich ironie die
eigen
der einzige wirklich gestandene
bundespolitiker ist er könnte vielleicht
wenn flucht von beiden parteien von cdu
csu was ich das weniger von den grünen
doch statt sind dann könnte er noch mal
eingreifen momentan sieht es aber nicht
so aus
von hennig das sind drei gebürtigen es
ist die da antreten
zwei davon haben inzwischen einen
wahlkreis im osten kurioserweise ein und
denselben können sich die ostdeutschen
denn in diesen kandidaten reichen
wiederfinden
na ja man hat ja an angela merkel
gesehen dass es nicht zwangsläufig so
ist das eine ostdeutsche kandidatinnen
die liebe oder die unterstützung aus
deutsche wähler bekommt also angela
merkel hat ihre machtbasis und viele
unterstützer im osten ja gerade verloren
weil viele enttäuscht davon waren dass
die kanzlerin die aus dem osten kommt so
wenig die leute dort verstanden hat in
den letzten jahren das heißt es gibt in
der region hier in der ich lebe durchaus
große offenheit für kandidaten die aus
anderen gebieten des des landes kommen
wir haben hier sehr viele
ministerpräsidenten gehabt die gebürtige
westdeutsche sind das heißt es ist kein
nachteil
wenn wir mal keinen ostdeutschen
spitzenkandidaten haben zumal bei der
vorigen bundestagswahl es viele
spitzenkandidaten aus dem osten gab
jetzt ist es anders ich glaube worauf es
ankommt ist wie diese kandidaten sich
positionieren und ob sie verstanden
haben dass man wahlen im osten verlieren
kann dass es wird natürlich interessant
für mich zu beobachten sein
herr florack wenn man geld übrig hat
sollte man das im moment eigentlich in
umfrageinstitute investieren
diese umfragen haben hochkonjunktur wird
da wenn man sich dass jetzt die
diskussion die auch auf diese umfragen
aufbaut mal so anzieht wird da das fell
des bären verteilt bevor er erlegt ist
ja in der tat ich würde sogar so weit
gehen zu sagen dass es im moment gar
nicht lohnt viel geld in solche
instrumente zu verwenden denn wir wissen
ja gar nicht wie überhaupt die
politische lage sich im september
darstellt das mutet jetzt zwei in
normalzeiten wie eine kurze zeit an aber
in dieser pandemie und in diesem
pandemie geschehen ist das eine halbe
ewigkeit
denn wir wissen nicht ob möglicherweise
das was uns bisher so lange in atem
gehalten hat im september irgend eine
faktische rolle spielt oder ob wir dann
alle energie impften republik leben und
sich völlig andere fragen stellen als
das panini geschehen insofern sind diese
stimmungsbilder die man da jetzt im
moment einfangen kann noch mal besonders
kritisch zu hinterfragen und auch in
ihre halbwertzeit aus meiner sicht nicht
besonders belastbar
wir haben erleben im moment so was wie
eine werbung euphorie und manche
vergleichen da schon mit dem sogenannten
schulz zug von 2017 wo ein kandidat auch
wie eine feuerwerksrakete hochgeschossen
ist um alsbald zu vergnügen
ist das vergleichbar oder werden da
äpfel mit birnen verglichen
na ja also es gibt die die gefahr davon
hat ja daraufhin von luca schon
hingewiesen
die gefahr ist viereinhalb monate vor
der wahl so gut dazustehen ist eine
gewisse würde denn über diese lange zeit
diese werte zu halten nicht zu stolpern
ist schwierig und ich glaube bei den
grünen hört man jedenfalls die sind am
anfang als diese umfragen 27 28 sahen
waren denen das gar nicht so wohl weil
wir ja auch alle auch aus der medienwelt
diesen effekt kennen wenn es dann mal
zwei prozent runter geht
stürzen sich alle darauf die
journalisten aber auch die politischen
gegner und dann kann es eben auch sehr
schnell runter rauschen trotzdem halte
ich die fälle wer bock und schulz nicht
wirklich für vergleichbar weil die spd
auch schon damals in einer krise war
sich ihre rolle eigentlich nicht richtig
gefunden hat in diesen neuen
parteiengefüge und da war der schuld so
eine art heilsbringer und alle
hoffnungen haben sich auf ihn geworfen
und er hat versucht aber sozusagen als
als einzel gestalt einzel lichtgestalt
die spd aus dieser krise heraus zu
ziehen und dann bald relativ schnell
klar das ist zerplatzt und dann stand
die spd eben auch wirklich mit leeren
händen da während der aufschwung der
grünen ja nicht alleine mit der person
annalena baerbock verbunden ist sondern
schon vorher begonnen hat die themen auf
die die grünen immer schon gesetzt haben
haben jetzt konjunktur werden auch von
anderen parteien jetzt als die
entscheidenden zentralen themen
angesehen und das fundament der grünen
ist jetzt eben deutlich breiter als eine
einzelne person
und wenn annalena baerbock jetzt
irgendwie strafen oder sonst was würde
wären da eben auch noch viele auf die
auf die man zurückfallen könnte es gibt
ja ein sprichwort nicht schwerer zu
ertragen als eine reihe von guten tagen
mit euphorie umzugehen ist manchmal
nicht einfach ist das eine hypothek
absolut eine ungeheure würde würde ich
sogar sagen weil ich geb pro box gerecht
die lage ist vom prinzip ja völlig
anders und unvergleichbar die grünen
haben ein großes alleinstellungsmerkmal
das ist die klimapolitische frage die
anderen parteien cdu csu wie auch spd
versuchen das regelrecht zu
neutralisieren besonders entlarvend
wirtschaftsminister altmaier der
verkürzung sagte wir machen jetzt auch
höhere maßgaben dann müssen wir über
dieses klima thema im wahlkampf nicht
mehr sprechen wir ziehen ein klima
politischen konsens natürlich aus sicht
der grünen eine absurde vorstellung sie
werden auf meinem eindruck nach dieses
alleinstellungsmerkmal nicht verlieren
aber die sorge darum dass diese
projektionsfläche bernburg ein stück
weit die rolle der thematischen
besondere bedeutung der grünen übernimmt
oder ihr eine neue projektionsflächen
rolle übertragen das ist dann doch dem
schutzeffekt nicht vergleichbar aber es
ist sogar fast noch abgehobener und das
kann für sie eine enorme hypothek werden
es ist ja mittlerweile so dass sich an
dieser figur auch durchaus im positiven
sinne verwertbar das ist
auch kapital eine geschlechterfrage
auftut das ist eine identifikationsfigur
für frauen dieses alters für jüngere die
generationsfrage wird regelrecht darauf
aufgezogen es ist die emanzipation frage
die ihr quasi über geholfen wird sie
muss in all diese fußstapfen treten und
darüber steht die große frage die
natürlich dann aufgemacht wird bringt
sie die erfahrung mit sind die grünen
vor allem auch und das ist dann das
eigentlich was vielleicht als hypothek
im hinteren schlummert im hintern zeigt
sind die grünen so geschüttelt dass man
ihnen das kanzleramt anvertrauen kann
und in dieser situation die autorität
aufzuweisen und aufzubringen die
beispielsweise im zuge jetzt der
programmdebatte der grünen erforderlich
sein so ist zum beispiel nur daran
denken dass ein teil der grünen ist
glaube ich ein antrag von sind 300 oder
100 grünen-mitglieder die sagen wir
wollen den titel deutschland alles ist
drin nicht als programmtitel haben dort
die autorität zu haben als annalena
baerbock zu sagen natürlich wir wollen
kanzler brennen und parteiführung für
deutschland übernehmen also kann der
titel und muss so bleiben
das wird eine große aufgabe für sie sein
weil natürlich jetzt die erwartung im
moment sind und das ist ein 1 1 1 eine
ganz ganz neue situation für die grünen
zwischen den einzelnen kandidatinnen und
kandidaten so ein bisschen hin und her
springen frau wenig euphorie ist ja eine
eigenschaft der armin laschet und olaf
scholz im moment zumindest sagen müssen
wie sieht es denn bei den beiden mit dem
rückhalt in der eigenen partei aus also
ein ost problem haben viele parteien am
größten ist es gerade für die cdu das
ließ sich besichtigen in der vorigen
woche beziehungsweise vor anderthalb
wochen als hans-georg maßen in thüringen
zum direkt wahlkreis kandidaten gewählt
worden ist das ist ja nun ein kandidat
mit dem sich die allermeisten im
bundesvorstand der cdu überhaupt nicht
anfreunden können
inklusive arena
trotzdem ist er gewählt worden und dann
muss man sich fragen woher das kommt das
war kein zufall das war auch kein
versehen das ist nicht mal so
durchgerutscht sondern das wahrzeichen
für ein größeres problem in der union
und das problem sieht so aus dass viele
in konservativere in dieser partei und
viele konservative finden sich eben im
osten deswegen sieht es aus wie in ost
problem ich glaube es ist nicht in ost
problem ist zeigt sich nur im osten
besonders viele konservative sind
unzufrieden mit dem kurs der cdu mit dem
kurs den angela merkel geprägt hat mit
dem kurs den ihre nachfolgerin annegret
kramp karrenbauer dann mit ein paar
veränderungen auch weiter vorangetrieben
hat dieser kurs der mitte die
flüchtlingspolitik der ausstieg aus der
atomkraft die beendigung der wehrpflicht
das waren alles entscheidungen die viele
konservative nicht gutgeheißen haben und
deswegen haben sie irgendwann angefangen
und hier kommt das problem ihre ganz
eigenen strategischen entscheidungen zu
treffen
die machen jetzt einfach die politik die
ihnen gefällt das betrifft viele
funktionäre vor allem in ostdeutschland
man sah das vor einem jahr in thüringen
als die cdu gemeinsam mit der afg und
der fdp ein ministerpräsidenten namens
thomas kemmerich gewählt hat das sah
hinterher manchmal aus wie ein versehen
aber es war kein versehen
das lag daran dass viele in dieser
partei entschieden haben
statt einen ministerpräsidenten der
linken zu unterstützen nämlich bodo
ramelow dann tun wir uns doch lieber mit
der afg zusammen im zweifel ein
ähnlicher fall wenn auch nicht ganz
gleichzusetzen ist jetzt der von
hans-georg maßen main rechnet maßen die
höchsten chancen aus diesen wahlkreis zu
gewinnen da es ein schwieriger wahlkreis
in südthüringen und deswegen wählt man
ihn obwohl man weiß dass armin laschet
davon überhaupt nicht begeistert ist und
leicht selbst hat etwas kluges getan
muss man sagen er wusste genau dass er
gar nicht die autorität hat das noch zu
verhindern er ist nicht nach thüringen
gefahren und hat mit der faust auf den
tisch geschlagen und gesagt es reicht
mir jetzt das macht ihr bitte nicht denn
das funktioniert nicht das hat schon bei
annegret kramp karrenbauer nicht
funktioniert die ist gescheitert als
cdu-vorsitzende weise die thüringen
krise nicht
gemanagt bekam und laschet hat sich
jetzt erst mal zurückgenommen hat die
dinge laufen lassen und hat entschieden
eines zu tun was ich auch für relativ
kluge hielt und halte er hat friedrich
merz eingebunden er ist ein wichtiger
teil seines wahlkampfes geworden und das
finde ich schon erstaunlich denn noch
vor ein paar monaten wir erinnern uns
alle sind beide gegeneinander angetreten
die waren konkurrenten und auch sehr
unterschiedlich in ihrer politischen
ausrichtung
kurioserweise hat der machtkampf
zwischen armin laschet und markus söder
dazu geführt dass laschet und märz sich
irgendwie noch näher gekommen sind und
jetzt gemeinsam dafür kämpfen dass die
cdu wieder den kanzler stellt und märz
ist der einzige partei prominente würde
ich sagen der eine große der die
konservativen in der cdu vor allem im
osten begeistert und jetzt dass hier
eine chance für armin laschet liegt er
jetzt haben sie die cdu schon
allumfassend eigentlich hier dargestellt
man hätte vor wenigen jahren noch gar
nicht geglaubt die viel basisdemokratie
in der cdu möglich ist jetzt martin
vortrag wenn man sich ansieht armin
laschet ist im moment ziemlich lädiert
nicht nur wegen der ostdeutschen
parteimitgliedern die von denen manche
unbotmäßig sind auch wegen der art wie
die kanzlerkandidatur über die bühne
geht bei olaf scholz hat man das gefühl
er steht ja vielleicht etwas besser da
in der öffentlichkeit im moment dass er
aber bestenfalls in der partei geduldet
ist ja und ich glaube dass diese
personalfrage auch darüber hinwegtäuscht
dass für diese bundestagswahl ja auch
ganz andere dinge mindestens auch
maßgeblich sein werden ich glaube das
darf man nicht vergessen und dann zwei
willich anschneiden das eine ist dass
wir zwar immer auf kandidaten und
personen konzentriert sind sie aber
immer träger von programmatik sind und
auch identifikationsfiguren für die
partei und die kandidaten bewertungen ja
nicht alleine nur nach sympathiepunkten
verteilt ist sondern person
ali sierung in der politik ja immer auch
mit denkt wie ist die passgenauigkeit
zur jeweiligen partei zur programmatik
und die zweite dimension und das ist
dann geht dann über die einzelnen
parteien hinaus
wer ist eigentlich anschlussfähig für
koalitionsbildung und das glaube ich
dass eine engführung wenn man sich allzu
sehr auf diese drei figuren konzentriert
aus dem blick zu behalten
wo vielleicht doch schließungs und
öffnungs mechanismen gegenüber
bestimmten neuen koalitions formaten da
sind und was im september auch gefordert
und gefragt ist denn wir haben in der
bundesrepublik bis auf 98 immer durch
das erlebt was wir sagen wir mal
dosierten machtwechseln wir haben immer
irgendeine partei die aus der vormaligen
bundesregierung sich auch in die neue
bundesregierung gerettet hat das wird
gemutmaßt ich diesmal auch der fall sein
die union oder die spd werden für die
neue bundesregierung eine wichtige rolle
spielen und trotzdem kann je nachdem wer
es ist davon ein sehr unterschiedliches
signal ausgehen nämlich ein eher
oppositionell geprägter reflex einer
veränderung weg von der großen koalition
weniger staatstragend neuer aufbruch und
sozusagen abweichungen von merkel dafür
kann man sich mal sehr unterschiedliche
koalitionen vorstellen während man sich
genauso viele und unterschiedliche
formate vorstellen kann für ein weiter
so und wurde eine unterschiedliche
kandidaten auch für diese weiter so
botschaften stehen und deswegen muss man
glaube ich den blick über die parteien
auch auf die koalitionsarithmetik
hinrichten
und auch da überlegen welcher kandidat
ist eigentlich in welche richtung
besonders anschlussfähig und dann
wandelt sich auch sicher das bild der
wahrnehmung und auch der politischen
möglichkeiten die aus dieser wahl
möglicherweise sich ergeben können ich
glaube aber trotzdem wenn ich da
vielleicht kein gretchen kann dass
diesmal die person ungemein eine
ungemeine rolle spielen das liegt
aufgrund an einer gewissen nähe auch von
cdu csu und spd die partei unterschiede
sind in einem gewissen maße
abgeschliffen und meinem verständnis
nach ist die ironie dass das ironische
darin besteht dass die spd weit stärker
hinter olaf scholz steht als
beispielsweise die cdu/csu hinter armin
laschet ich würde auch das nicht das
muss ich ihnen sagen freuen ich will dir
widersprechen ich würde das vorschicken
von friedrich merz der gewissermaßen die
rolle der letzten projektionsfigur in
der cdu csu übernommen hat die cdu muss
sich bewusst machen die basis der cdu
ist zwei mal zutiefst gekränkt wurden
die erste projektionsfläche die große
projektionsfläche gerade für die
konservativen im osten war friedrich
merz der 4 gegen laschet die zweite
und der zweite heitz bringen aber markus
söder der fiel wiederum durch und jetzt
kommt ein absolut geschwächter rasche
und muss seinen größten widersacher
friedrich merz der sich dann mit ihm in
der tat koaliert hat und markus söder zu
verhindern er muss ihn nach
ostdeutschland schicken weil er selber
quasi dort keine reputation genießt das
ist eine ungemeine schwäche unter und
dann wird er auf der anderen seite von
einem markus höhe regelrecht vor sich
hergetrieben
er sagt mit den methoden der neunziger
jahre von friedrich merz wird uns
wahnsinnig gutes tun erkennt sich bei
hedgefonds aus also ich war eine sport
wir müssen also sehen die große frage
wer sich hier noch hinter armin laschet
stellt und die autorität sehe ich auch
nicht frau heimlich so klar gestärkt
dadurch dass er sagt in der tat sie
haben völlig recht ich habe ohnehin
keinen einfluss
ob er maßen gewählt wird ich bin mal
gespannt wie herr maßen sich einlegen
lassen wird die ard wird schon vieles
dafür tun dass sein maßen in thüringen
gewählt wird da wird eine wunderbare
erststimmen kampagne für in maßen für
den bundestagswahlkampf stattfinden und
dann wird dermaßen herren laschet noch
eine menge ärger bereiten das tut er
übrigens jetzt schon mit all den
anwürfen die jetzt stattfinden in puncto
rechtsgerichtete herr scholz hat es da
wesentlich leichter und das ist die
einzige vielleicht vorhandene stärke von
olaf scholz olaf scholz steht einer
zutiefst geschockten partei vor
er wurde nicht parteivorsitzender es
gewissermaßen vielleicht kanzlerkandidat
ja aus einem schockmoment weil die
partei begriffen hat nachdem wir ihn als
parteivorsitzenden verhindert haben
gegen die gesamte parteiführung sind wir
so geschwächt wir müssen uns jetzt
hinter olaf scholz versammeln und das
einzige was die spd den anderen beiden
parteien sehr voraus also das werden die
grünen noch glaube ich hart erleben das
ist ein parteiprogramm hinter dem sich
boulahrouz übrigens auch seine schwerste
prüfung hinter sich haben denn eine rede
konnte olaf scholz noch nie halten die
hat er jetzt gehalten jetzt wird er in
talkshows sitzen müssen da kann er klare
sätze einfacher und klarer sagt ich
mache das die alle reden nur ich werde
handeln der ist damit durch die anderen
parteien und vor allem die grünen werden
glaube ich noch schwierigkeiten haben
diese symbiose von partei und programm
die die spd aus angst hinter dem
kandidaten scholz sich hat versammlungs
und diese hinzukriegen
das ist die letzte chance für olaf
scholz gilt du hast keine chance nutze
sie
und ich will und armin laschet kämpft
weniger gegen annalena baerbock und olaf
scholz sondern eher gegen die
ostdeutsche cdu die csu
also armin laschet kämpft muss auch
sicherlich an allen fronten kämpfen ich
glaube wir haben jetzt sehr aufregende
wochen innerhalb von cdu und csu gesehen
ich halte es auch nicht für
ausgeschlossen dass im zuge der nächsten
wochen sich da die lage etwas beruhigt
das eben viele landesverbände die basis
sich schüttelt und eben dann doch sagt
jetzt kämpfen wir eben dann zusammen es
geht ums kanzleramt halte ich durchaus
für möglich dass ich da die lage doch
mal beruhigt auch in der vergangenheit
hat es ja hin und wieder mal ordentlich
gekracht zwischen cdu und csu und wenn
es ernst wurde dann standen sie eben
doch zu spd habe ich eine etwas andere
einschätzung ja die partei ist in einem
schockmoment und der kitt jetzt auch
zusammen
die frage ist nur wie stark ist so ein
bündnis das aus angst gemacht ist und
ich glaube nicht sehr stark also wir
dürfen nicht vergessen ist es wirklich
noch nicht lange her als saskia esken
und weiter norbert walter borjans die
parteivorsitz hingegen olaf scholz
angetreten sind im kampf um den
parteivorsitz und sich öffentlich
gestritten haben saskia esken saß in
einer talkshow und hat olaf scholz
abgesprochen ein aufrechter
sozialdemokrat zu sein das ist ja alles
nicht weg ist es auch nicht weg dieser
die sich dieser spalt den es gibt
zwischen olaf scholz und sein ja sehr
realpolitischen sag ich mal überzeugung
und dem wahlprogramm wo er nun auch ganz
andere sachen vertreten muss weil die
basis das einfordert das ist jetzt alles
überschattet oder oder sag ich mal diese
diese probleme die die spd hat diese
diese internen konflikte sind jetzt eben
durch diese dieses angst moment dass die
partei tatsächlich sorge hat vollkommen
unterzugehen strebt mich so den
vordergrund werden auch nach außen hin
vollkommen kaschiert aber in der partei
rumort es natürlich weiter und all diese
probleme diese strukturellen probleme
was ist eigentlich die rolle einer
arbeiterpartei in einer zeit in der iss
die arbeiterschaft als basis der spd gar
nicht mehr gibt sondern sie eben in
großen teil 2 fdp und linkspartei über
gelaufen ist diese frage hat die spd
immer noch nicht beantwortet also in der
partei rumort ist gehört eigentlich bei
union und bei spd martin ragg dieses
problem haben die bündnisgrünen sieht
man mal von den unberechenbaren wollten
eines baden-württembergischen
oberbürgermeisters ab
der im moment auf ego trip ist dieses
problem haben die grünen nicht früher
hatten die flügelkämpfe der partei ja
auch einen hohen unterhaltungswert in
der öffentlichkeit woher kommt diese
harmonie hat man da erkannt mit einem
flohzirkus kann ich nicht ins kanzleramt
einziehen
ja die grünen sind sicher anders als die
beiden anderen großen volksparteien
nicht damit gestraft allzuviel
ambivalenz auszuhalten das gilt
einerseits innerparteilich aber
gleichzeitig auch für die wählerschaft
weil die wählerschaft der grünen dann
doch im vergleich zur union und spd ein
bisschen homogener daherkommt das
verhindert gleichzeitig aber auch dass
dann die bäume so wahnsinnig in den
himmel wachsen es gibt dann insofern
eine art gläserne decke an die
vielleicht die grünen auch stoßen an der
sie vielleicht jetzt sind das wissen wir
einfach nicht da spekulieren werden
prinzip
die frage ist ob wir informiert oder
uninformiert spekulieren müssen und ich
würde ein bisschen dafür plädieren
anzunehmen dass unser informations
gerade in wir einbringen können doch
beschränkt da ist in diesem jahr denn
wir kommen jetzt aus einer wirklich
tiefgreifenden und fundamentalen
veränderung der vergangenen monate und
wie die pandemie mit all ihren
auswirkungen sich auswirken wird im
september ich glaube es wäre vermessen
anzunehmen wir könnten das jetzt
wirklich ernsthaft beurteilen und wir
könnten aus der vergangenheit allzu sehr
was ableiten für die zukunft ich will es
mal an zwei themen aufmachen die frage
dass beispielsweise klimaschutz zwar
latent vorhanden gewesen ist immer als
thema auch durch die pandemien weg aber
wie stark trägt das noch im september
wenn möglicherweise die große koalition
ein teil dieses themas mit einem neuen
klimaschutzgesetz abräumt wir wissen es
eigentlich nicht ganz genau und so kann
man auch bei der spd möglicherweise
punkte sehen die wir im moment in der
vergangenheit vermisst haben es wurde
gerade angesprochen was ist das profil
einer arbeiterpartei
die spd hat ja weite teile auch der
finanz- und wirtschaftspolitischen
maßnahmen in dieser corinna pandemie
auch hässig verantwortet in der
bundesregierung und da stellen sich auch
völlig neue fragen von daseinsvorsorge
auf kommunaler ebene usw
da ist die gemengelage völlig anders als
vor einem jahr vielleicht taucht das
auch der spd neues leben an
wenn sie glaubhaft vermitteln kann dass
sie darauf noch antworten hat insofern
würde ich sagen dass der blick in die
vergangenheit
bei uns in diesem jahr sehr viel weniger
weiterhilft als bei vergangenen wahlen
und da ein extrem hohes maß an
unsicherheit und auch
wettbewerbssituationen drinsteckt und
aus einer welle perspektive heraus man
sich das ja eigentlich nur wünschen kann
dass bei dieser wahl in der tat etwas
zur wahl steht denn vielfach haben wir
in der vergangenheit hier die erfahrung
vieler wähler auch transportiert
bekommen dass sie gerade gesagt haben
eine wahl führt eigentlich nicht zu
unterscheidbarkeit danach sondern wir
wählen und das hat eigentlich keinen
großen effekt und da würde schon
vermuten dass wir im september dafür die
parteien auch ein riesenspiel feld haben
auf dem sie sich sehr viel diverser
aufstellen können und wo auch wirklich
was zur wahl steht anders als das
vielleicht bei vergangenen
bundestagswahlen der jüngeren
vergangenheit der fall gewesen ist wenig
kann man sagen dass im parteiensystem
der bundesrepublik jetzt im vorfeld der
bundestagswahl die karten richtig neu
gemischt werden
also zumindest für mich als journalistin
und auch als bürgerin gilt dass ich mich
auf diesen wahlkampf so voll wie ich
mich wahrscheinlich noch nie auf einen
wahlkampf geführt habe und das liegt
daran dass der ausgang so ungewiss ist
dass man heute noch überhaupt nicht
sagen wird sagen kann wer im oktober
november je nach themen waren dann die
koalitionsverhandlungen abgeschlossen
sind werde als kanzler ins kanzleramt
einzieht das kann sicherheit armin
laschet die größten chancen
es kann genauso gut annalena baerbock
werden wir haben darüber vorher schon
gesprochen aber auch olaf scholz hat ja
noch chancen
er muss ja nur in anführungsstrichen
stärker werden als die grünen
und dann müsste er es schaffen eine
ampel koalition zu bilden aus spd grünen
und fdp ist auch nicht ausgeschlossen
ist auch denkbar dass wir in diese
situation geraten
und deswegen schaue ich mit großem
interesse auf das was da passiert und
jeder mensch in deutschland der sich für
politik interessiert der kann sich
glaube ich nur freuen über das große
angebot das wir gerade haben und ich
will vielleicht nach einsatz zu den
grünen sagen
weil über die gerade eben gesprochen
worden ist ich finde die gründen haben
eine große herausforderung sie sind
immer noch eine partei für menschen die
in großstädten wohnen für junge menschen
und für wohlhabende
das ist auch völlig legitim da gibt es
ein großes klientel wenn die grünen
wirklich die kanzlerin stellen wollen
dann müssen sie es schaffen jenseits
dieser klientel irgendwie ansprechbar zu
sein beziehungsweise dann müssen sie
auch leute überzeugen die älter sind die
nicht wohlhabend sind und die nicht in
großstädten leben dass das thema
die frage stellt sich in ostdeutschland
besonders weil aus deutsch weil ich aus
deutschland jetzt nicht unbedingt als
jungen großstädtisch und wohlhabend
bezeichnen würde aber sie stellt sich
auch in anderen teilen des landes
und das wird die große herausforderung
sein ich glaube auch nicht dass annalena
baerbock durch diesen wahlkampf kommt
indem sie immer nur sagt die klimakrise
ist wichtig und die müssen wir jetzt
lösen sondern sie hat die frage zu
beantworten wie die grünen diese frage
eigentlich lösen wollen und antworten
darauf könnten auch viele ängste
auslösen das heißt immer dann wenn es
konkret wird geraten die grünen auch
schnell in schwierigkeiten ich erinnere
mich an dieses diese eine maßnahme die
sie da ich glaube vor vier jahren oder
vor acht jahren korrigieren sie mich
eingebracht haben das war das schnitzel
verbot donnerstags im öffentlichen
kantinen
da hatten sie einen wochenlangen
shitstorm zu ertragen also immer dann
wenn es konkret wird geraten die grünen
in schwierigkeiten
das kann ihnen natürlich auch in diesem
jahr passieren deswegen versuchen sie so
unkonkret wie nur möglich zu bleiben und
andere sein müssen sie klarere antworten
geben wenn sie eben leute ansprechen
wollen die nicht zu ihren natürlichen
klientel gehören das heißt die große
herausforderung für die grünen steht
noch vor und als journalistin kann man
interessiert und gespannt freudig zu
gucken und das mache ich ja gut also ich
glaube der veggie day war da 2013 lassen
dass er den gedanken gleich kurz noch
weiter spinnen von lykke li na ja die
unverbrauchte unbelastete unverdorbene
newcomerin die wahl jetzt ja auch vieles
neu gedacht neu gemacht werden muss da
setzt sie dann allerdings auf eine
ziemlich wagemutige wahlbevölkerung
absolut das ist das eigentlich
wahnsinnig spannende phänomen das wir
und das nämlich nicht nur um es auch
bisschen anders noch zu konsultieren
nicht nur aus der interessen geneigten
brille des journalisten und des bürgers
war wir haben es mit einer
unwahrscheinlich irritierenden situation
zu tun dass die eigentlich angestammten
parteien für die kanzlerschaft in einer
historisch ja nicht nur die klimakrise
betreffen den historischen lage
sondergleichen dimensionen
sondergleichen ihre führungsrolle in
diesem wahlkampf an eine newcomer partei
mit einer newcomer kandidatin verloren
haben diese prüfung auf die
ernsthaftigkeit wie die grünen übrigens
auch interessanterweise wenn sie daran
denken wie sie jetzt ihre kandidatur von
einer der bewerber begründet ab und an
der box selbst noch gesagt hat ich will
eine rolle als führende an führender
stelle wahrnehmen die grünen waren gar
nicht überzeugt dass sie in einer
solchen beschleunigung wirklich um platz
eins würden spielen können gibt es war
zwar angekündigt aber das ist in einer
derartigen weise nach oben gehen würde
ist natürlich jetzt über viereinhalb
monate im zwar nicht nur in der
klimakrise eine absolute prüfung auf die
tauglichkeit dieser kanzlerkandidat in
bernburg das geht in der frage der
außenpolitik sofort zur sache
bisher ist sie natürlich klassisch ich
sag mal joschka fischer in potenz ist es
böse aber es ist ein stück wert absolut
transatlantisch die große frage ist wie
wird das der neuen multipolaren welt
wirklich gerecht sie ist absolut treu an
der seite der amerikanischen freunde so
würde sie es wahrscheinlich fast
bezeichnet das heißt aber die frage
taucht auch er ist das reicht das dann
gibt es die ganzen themen der
identitätspolitik das wird bei den
grünen was die spd nur in ansätzen
erlebt hat aufkommen sie steht natürlich
ab und sie hat auch schon manche
interviews geben wo man merkte dass ich
natürlich einerseits voll der jungen
generation recht geben will aber sie
darf nicht verkennen und da hat frau
ihnen ich völlig recht dass sie auch die
älteren mitnehmen muss wir haben einen
generationskonflikt gerade in den themen
der identitätspolitik des sternchens und
all diesen sachen der gender sprache wo
es auf der einen seite richtig ist die
bedürfnisse zu erkennen ist im alter
wird auf auch auf die die abwehr die
älteren mit einem gewissen vergessen
dass in einer koalition mit der linken
noch größer werden dieses problem vom
beruf geht mir ginge würde ich gern noch
sagen und zwar ist das nämlich ganz
interessant die analyse der beiden
die kollegen kollegin teile ich und
interessantes man die grünen beobachtet
dass man sieht es gibt diese botschaft
die lautet fürchtet euch nicht vor uns
ja und das ist eine ganz klare botschaft
die man immer wieder in verschiedenen
variationen hört auf dem parteitag 219
sagte baerbock unsere er unser klima
paket ist etwa so revolutionär wie ein
bausparvertrag ja also habt keine angst
wir machen nicht die große revolution
sie hat eine weile hatten sie dieses
wurde radikal ist das neue realistisch
dieses radikal ist vollkommen aus der
sprache der grünen verschwunden weil sie
den leuten die angst nehmen weil sie
sagen wir nehmen euch an die hand und
begleiten euch durch diesen prozess und
vor allem reden wir euch überhaupt nicht
in die persönliche lebensführung rein
also kein budget mehr keine flugverbote
mir nichts mehr
und da wiederum ist natürlich eine ein
widerspruch tut sich auf es ist eben
nicht ganz zu erklären wie man jetzt
klimaziele denn erreichen will ohne den
menschen tatsächlich vorschriften also
wir müssen unser leben ist das ist ja
allem auch wissenschaftlern klar wenn
man nicht irgendwie co2 ein wenig co2
einspart wird man diese ziele nicht
erreichen und das da gibt es bei den
grünen natürlich brüche sage ich mal in
der begründung
aber die strategie ist jetzt wir möchten
eben ein breites wähler publikum
erreichen und vor allem geht es um die
merkel stimmen das wird auch unter den
grünen so gesagt also lieber ein paar am
linken rand möglicherweise verlieren
enttäuschen oder ein zwei leute der
berliner landesverband der dann über den
indianerhäuptling diskutiert oder soja
dass man das dann laufen lässt aber dass
man im prinzip als partei sagt die mögen
den begriff volkspartei nicht aber darum
geht es im kern auf dem land bei den
alten und bei denen sage ich mal liberal
konservativen punkte zu machen wobei sie
auf fortschritte gemacht haben das
stimmt auf dem land sind sie immer noch
schwächer aber wenn man sich zum
beispiel hessen oder baden-württemberg
anguckt gibt es auch schon ganz viele
kommunalpolitiker von den grünen also
auch nicht nur die die städte sondern
auch auf dem land färben sich 40 die
karte langsam grün also da hat sich auch
schon einiges getan in den letzten
jahren gefragt es geht ja auch um die
frage wie umgehen mit diesem furiosen
start von annalena baerbock
die rettungsboote die für armin laschet
und für olaf scholz jetzt zu wasser
gelassen werden soll die tragen die
namen erfahrung und kompetenz ist das
eine kluge strategie gegen annalena
baerbock die eben mit dem newcomer stil
und der frische in der politik
argumentiert und vorprescht also wenn
wir die kandidaten in den blick nehmen
ist das bild von den newcomern sicher
richtig aber ich will ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen relativieren denn von den
grünen als newcomer part zu sprechen
finde ich verkürzt und auch insbesondere
in der erfahrung der corinna zeit
eigentlich sehr eindimensional auf den
berliner betrieb ausgerichtet denn in
der tat sind die grünen die kleinste
oppositionspartei sie sind da in der tat
in einer anderen rolle gefangen aber wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dass wir alle in
den vergangenen monaten erlebt haben wie
wirkt möchte ich auch landespolitik sein
kann und wie durchschlagend
steuerungsfähig auch landesregierungen
der pandemie waren und da haben die
grünen in vielen vielen ländern mit
regiert sie sind ja längst heimliche
regierungspartei und zwar nicht nur über
den bundesrat sondern insbesondere in
der korona zeit über die landesregierung
sie haben viel professionelles personal
in den landesverbänden die da
aufgestellt worden sind und insofern
trägt aus meiner sicht dieses bild des
newcomers nicht und ich glaube dass
insofern die grünen auch beide rollen
bedienen können sie haben einerseits mit
annalena baerbock
eine junge kandidatin ich glaube auch
dass diese frage des geschlechts
natürlich auch eine rolle spielen und
insbesondere bei den grünen
mobilisierungs punkte bringen kann und
gleichzeitig können sie mit fug und
recht auf ihre regierungserfahrung
vorweisen und für die anderen parteien
ist natürlich immer die frage was hat
man im köcher was zieht man jetzt nach
vorne und was sind die punkte mit denen
man wirklich nach vorne geht kann in der
tat wäre es ja fast fahrlässig wenn man
jetzt als amina stattlich auf regierungs
verfahren in nordrhein-westfalen
verweisen würde und bei olaf scholz auf
die regierungserfahrung die hier in
berlin mit bringen natürlich müssen sie
das ausspielen was am ende zählt im
september wissen wir einfach nicht
wollen wir wirklich aufbruch und einen
fundamentalen war
oder sind wir ganz zufrieden werden wir
uns in der neuen alten normalität
angefangen erfunden haben dass sie
vielleicht dann doch so weiter geht wie
wir irgendwie gewöhnt waren und wir
freuen uns dass wir so eine art
staatstragende union hat die als
regierungspartei mit einem gewissen
erbschafts anspruch ja fast in berlin
unterwegs ist wenn die noch da ist wir
wissen es einfach nicht ganz genau ich
glaube das macht insofern tragödien reiz
auch aus der aus der auseinandersetzung
dass die parteien mit diesen jeweiligen
es sozusagen spielen können und wir als
wähler dann uns was aussuchen
je nachdem welche präferenzen wie im
september dann wirklich ausgebildet auf
der anderen seite haben wir eine
gesellschaft im umbruch nicht nur wegen
der pandemie auch zum beispiel wegen der
digitalen revolution frau hennig die
themen wirtschaft bildung gesundheit
pflege klima steuern das werden so im
wesentlichen die themen sein die im
wahlkampf auch eine rolle spielen werden
wie verbindlich müssen denn dieses mal
diese wahlkampfversprechen die aus
diesen themen kommen sein
da fragen sie mich was ich finde
prognosen aufzustellen deswegen so
schwierig weil wir es jetzt noch
überhaupt nicht wissen wie dieses land
aus diesem block da und kommt also wir
wissen erst welche verheerungen der
locker und angerichtet haben wird auch
wirtschaftlicher natur wenn er denn dann
einmal endet und schließe ich mich an
flora kann es kann natürlich sein
wir kommen aus diesem lockdown und
erleben eine phase des aufschwungs eine
phase in der bürger sagen jetzt sind wir
bereit zu einer erneuerung wir haben
diese pandemie hinter uns gelassen wir
sind wir haben es überstanden wir trauen
uns jetzt etwas neues wir wollen eine
frühere oppositionspartei ins kanzleramt
wählen
und wir lassen uns auch auf
versprechungen ein die vielleicht ein
bisschen weniger konkret sind als wir es
uns wünschen würden es kann aber auch
sein und dafür gibt's ja auch ein paar
hin
wir sind inzwischen schon das dass es
die nächsten monate eigentlich ganz
schön hart werden viele unternehmen
haben jetzt schon mit
lieferschwierigkeiten zu kämpfen
es gibt jetzt schon viele rohstoffe auf
dem weltmarkt nicht mehr und es kann
sein dass werden eine wirtschaftlich
ganz schwierige situation geraten in der
sich die menschen dann eben doch wieder
nach einem kandidaten sehen der für
verlässlichkeit steht für den man
vertrauen kann bei dem man weiß woran
man ist das wäre dann wahrscheinlich
eher olaf scholz oder vielleicht armin
laschet weil man der cdu eben zutraut zu
regieren auch in schwierigen zeiten und
wenn die zeiten schwierig sind wünscht
man sich natürlich versprechungen
wünscht man sich aus sagen die so
konkret wie nur möglich sind das heißt
ich kann ihnen heute leider auch noch
nicht sagen wie die nächsten wochen
werden
ich hoffe natürlich dass wir gut aus
diesem lockdown kommen und mit einem
gefühl der beschwingtheit und mit einem
gefühl dinge anpacken zu können diesen
wahlkampf gehen welche partei auch immer
dann am besten abschneiden wird aber
gesagt ist es heute leider noch nicht
gut wenn man der hintergrund der frage
war ja dass es dieses mal wahrscheinlich
noch schwieriger werden wird den leuten
auch aufgrund der letzten vier jahre so
das blaue vom himmel herunter zu
versprechen dass auch ein auswirkungen
auf den wahlkampf stil haben
ich glaube dass unbedingt ich würde
sogar das was er florack in den raum
warf diese die polarität zwischen
erneuerung und kontinuität wollen die
leute plötzlich vielleicht erneuerung
ich würde es ein bisschen anders
beleuchten ich glaube dass die leute
allenfalls die erneuerung in dosierter
art haben wollen aber dass das
sicherheitsgefühl in diesen krisenzeiten
auch vor allem in dem augenblick wo es
sehr viel konkreter wird was zum
beispiel die klimawende bedeutet da
macht beispielsweise die fdp wir
sprechen ja gar nicht über die anderen
parteien aller leichteste punkte die
nehme ich jetzt genau durchbuchstabiert
was werden uns das eigentlich was wird
das vor kosten bedeuten was bedeutet
ganz konkret dann glaube ich relativiert
sich das gegenüber von erneuerung und
kontinuität und sicherheit ich glaube
das sicherheitsbedürfnis dieses gefühl
wir wissen eigentlich ziemlich genau wir
kommen aus ziemlich guten zeiten in
diesem
und auch wenn corona eine große zäsur
der bedeutet aber wir gehen harten
zeiten entgegen
geopolitisch international
klimapolitisch dass dieses gefühl eine
hypothek auch für die grünen gerade
werden kann sie müssen also wenn sie
nicht über schießen und daher ja auch
dieses zurücknehmen dieses erneuerungs
versprechen meinem eindruck nach immer
stark dosieren deswegen war übrigens
auch ich glaube dass damit die zentrale
der zentrale grund warum markus söder
diese ungemein popularität genoss er hat
nämlich sicherheit auf der einen seite
mit enorme autorität verkörpert weit
mehr als die anderen kandidaten ich
glaube dass wenn markus söder am start
wäre diese wahl
ganz anders die auseinandersetzung ganz
anders aussehe und für die cdu/csu ganz
anders zu schlagen wäre aber er hat ein
stück weit sehr abweichen von angela
merkel auch einen erneuerungs
versprechen übernommen hat eine
ausgesprochen fortschritts freundliche
klimapolitik weisen also all diese dinge
sicherheit auf der einen seite zu
verkörpern auch international für
deutschland als die stärkste machen
europa und trotzdem eine komponente von
erneuerungen zu bringen das ist glaube
ich die crux und das wird für eine
partei die zuallererst erneuerung
verspricht für die grünen das wird
glaube ich die herausforderung
verstanden spieler ganz kurzen eine in
ergänzung das grundsatzprogramm der grün
heißt er interessanterweise veränderung
schafft halt also versuchen sie genau
diese punkte
diesen spagat dieses zusammenbinden von
letztlich im grunde 22 unterschiedlichen
polen welche welchen handlungsspielraum
hat die neue regierung ja natürlich sage
ich mal die finanziellen möglichkeiten
werden künftig begrenzt da sein wir
haben ja alle gesehen wie die wir
millionenbeträge in den vergangenen
monaten und das volk gebracht habe ich
sag ich mal natürlich vollkommen zu
recht an die unternehmen alle die hilfen
wo man auf einmal doch woher kommt
eigentlich dieses ganze geld und da
jetzt geht es natürlich in zukunft
weiter und es ist auch eine debatte die
der grünen aber natürlich auch der
anderen parteien
wie will man wer zahlt am ende die
rechnung und wie will man den investor
investitionsstau den ist ja auch in
deutschland gibt also schaut man auf die
schulen schaut man auf die die autobahn
oder soja also es muss muss viel getan
werden
wer soll das bezahlen und dann gibt es
eben die finanzierungsmöglichkeiten des
staates sind begrenzt also schulden da
haben wir die schuldenbremse im
grundgesetz inwiefern soll die gelockert
werden unterschiedliche
in den unterschiedlichen parteien
steuern will man steuer erhöhen ja oder
nein und uns denn und das ist es im
wesentlichen also die oder will man
natürlich auch private zurückgreifen das
ist auch noch theoretisch eine
möglichkeit und das ist natürlich eine
frage die jetzt auch journalisten im
wahlkampf immer wieder stellen werden
wer große versprechungen macht muss auch
erklären wie er sie finanzieren soll und
jede art der finanzierung tut weh in
jahrzehnte lang ist in
politikwissenschaftlichen seminaren von
der bundesrepublik deutschland als einer
kanzler demokratie gesprochen worden
das bezieht sich vor allen dingen auf
die richtlinienkompetenz wie groß ist
denn die machtfülle der neuen chefin
oder des neuen chefs im bundeskanzleramt
ich gebe mal drei stichworte die grüne
basis die spd parteiführung oder die csu
je nachdem wer von den dreien einzieht
ist die wirklich noch so groß ja wir
sehen dass kanzler sich auch zum teil
emanzipieren sowohl vom tagesgeschäft
als auch natürlich von ihrer partei und
sie dann am ende auch ein bisschen über
den parteien schweben ich meine angela
merkel hat ein gewisser weise als so
eine präsidiale figur ja eigentlich ganz
gut deutlich gemacht warum wir da von
kanzler demokratie sprechen und
gleichzeitig haben wir immer erlebt dass
wir ja vielfach auch bestimmten
kandidaten die zugetraut haben dass sie
dieses amt ausfüllen könnten daran will
ich noch mal erinnern denn genau in
dieser kanzler losen zeit sind wir
eigentlich schon alle wissen dass angela
merkel nicht wieder antreten das macht
die ganze besonderheit dieser situation
deutlich
bisher war gewissermaßen der
kanzlerkandidat das erfolgloseste
ehrenamt der bundesrepublik was zu
vergeben war weil das immer so
aussichtslos war in dieser rolle
überhaupt irgend einem blumentopf zu
gewinnen und das ist diesmal erstmals so
dass man nicht gegen einen amtsinhaber
antritt und das macht genau das
interessante dieser konstellation aus
und jetzt schauen wir immer auf diese
großen kanzler zurück in ihrer
regierungszeit aber wir vergessen ein
bisschen wie sie angetreten sind
ich meine man kann an helmut kohl
erinnern den mann nicht zugetraut und
das waren falsch heraus als
ministerpräsident auf der bonner bühne
zu reüssieren
und denken wir mal an angela merkel
zurück und wie sie 2005 beäugt worden
dass wie kritisch einerseits in der
eigenen partei aber auch bei den
mitbewerbern dass man sich doch nicht
ernsthaft vorstellen konnte dass hier
eine so lange regierungszeit erfüllen
würde
das bestätigt sozusagen direkt
eigentlich die kirche these von der
kanzler demokratie aber sie entsteht
erst nach der wahl und durch das
regierungsgeschäft und nicht in der
projektion auf kandidaten im vorfeld
dieser wahl und deswegen ist da die
fallhöhe im moment besonders hoch und
ich würde behaupten ab oktober november
oder waren auch immer wieder eine neue
regierung haben wird sich auch bei
dieser neuen personen wieder dieser
kanzlerbonus sicher einstellen gut wir
haben jetzt noch 120 sekunden inklusive
verabschiedung irgendwelche dass eine
letzte frage von den drei
wahrscheinlichen koalitionsmöglichkeiten
wenn alle drei denkbar sind also
mehrheitsfähig sind im parlament also
grün schwarz oder schwarz grün ampel
oder links koalition zu welcher
koalition würde es kommen nach lage der
dinge
ach das ist lustig glaskugel ich sage
schwarz grün
also wie gesagt ich habe alle drei wären
möglich wären möglich das ist die
prämisse aber es kann ja nicht grün
schwarz und schwarz grüne ja wohl jeder
also ich versteh ich sagen kann dann
dass es am ehesten ist veränderung und
halt zusammen zu bringen was ja
offensichtlich eine sehnsucht ist dies
in einer breiten bevölkerung gibt sage
ich schwarz grün
das heißt auch über die ampel und links
koalition möglich wären trotzdem schwarz
grün die linkskoalition stehe ich völlig
aus und das halte ich für abgesucht das
hat auch übrigen habe er ganz schnell
zum punkt gebracht er hat nämlich die
linkspartei genötigt ein bekenntnis zur
zur nato abzugeben und daraufhin hat
janine wissler das von ihm erwünschten
gesagt sie hat mich besonders ein
kriegsbündnis nun damit ist die frage
erledigt das war von hayek nicht tun
damit hat er quasi sich nach links
abgeschottet damit ist die frage im raum
würden die grünen ist riskieren in einem
jamaika-bündnis vielleicht sogar unter
ihrer führung gehen das ist die frage
oder dann eben doch in schwarz grün als
kleinere konstellation das ist ja die
frage die im raum ist und da will ich
mir nicht sicher ob die grünen ist nicht
riskieren würden aber sonst denke ich
habe jetzt gar nicht genannt frau hennig
aber ampel grün schwarz oder links
koalition wird alle drei koalitionen
möglich wären für welche welche wird
kommen
ich bin mal mutig und sage ampel unter
führung der grünen
denn es wäre aus sicht der grünen gar
nicht so schlecht die cdu nicht in der
region zu haben soll damit die grünen
die die cdu erst mal in die opposition
zu schicken und das mit der spd zu
versuchen die ja durchaus gutes im
regieren und muss jetzt so lange zu
binden
zu wort kommen lassen er ihr tipp wir
sind am ende der sendung rechnerische
mehrheiten sind keine politischen und
deswegen kommen sie auf die kandidaten
an die in der lage sind ein bündnis zu
schmieden ich schließe gar nichts aus
noch der blockierten regierungsbildung
der letzten runde wäre ich nicht so
vermessen irgendein super zu geben dann
bedanke ich mich bei anhängig bei martin
florack bei pläne bobrowski und bei
albrecht von lucke liebe zuschauer
morgen in der phoenix runde urlaub trotz
corona was ist in europa möglich jetzt
folgt phoenix der tag mit thomas bade
mit der neuesten entwicklung aus israel
und den palästinensischen gebieten
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]